avec nous françois philippe champagne
ministre de l'innovation des sciences et
de l'industrie merci d'être là monsieur
champagne donc vous avez exprimé votre
mécontentement vous avez parlé de
frustration même à l'endroit de ses
fournisseurs qu'est ce que vous leur
avez dit lors de cette rencontre
aujourd'hui écoutez j'ai été la voix des
plus de 12 millions de canadiens
canadiennes aux pays qui ont dû faire
face cette part l'homme majeurs à
travers le pays ça a été mon premier
message deuxièmement la frustration des
commerçants aussi parce que savoir que
plusieurs entreprises à travers le pays
ne pouvait pas se connecter au service
interac projet ma frustration aussi des
gens qui sont dans le domaine des
services d'urgence parce qu'on sait que
le défunt ne fonctionnait pas comme ils
auraient dû fonctionner dans certaines
villes alors d'abord la frustration
deuxièmement je voudrais que c'était
inacceptable
point final c'est ce que j'ai dit aux
présidents des différentes compagnies
qui étaient là une fois que ce soit
s'est dit ensuite de ça moi j'ai demandé
plus de résilience oui et c'est là que
je leur ai dit je m'attends à ce que
vous fassiez un accord d'ici les 60
prochains jours à partir d'aujourd'hui
qui vont faire trois choses pas bon on
va codifié l'assistance mutuelle
deuxièmement on va avoir le service qui
va nous permettre en cas d'urgence
d'avoir l'itinérance en cas d'urgence
automatique et troisièmement qu'on
aurait un protocole sur la communication
communication avec les clients mais
aussi communication avec les autorités
pour être en mesure de mieux prévenir
évidemment les situations parce que
l'idée derrière tout ça c'est que on
choisit pas les moments de ces pannes
l'ont choisi pas comment ça arrive mais
on peut choisir d'être mieux préparés
alors clairement
mon message était clair et je voudrais
que les gens étaient en mode écoute
aujourd'hui comment ça a été reçu c'est
l'ouverture de la part de ses joueurs le
point que c'était pas le jour pour être
en contradiction je pense aujourd'hui
parce que ma voix c'était celle des plus
de 12 millions de canadiens canadiennes
qui avait cette frustration là et je
pense qu'ils comptent tout le monde
qu'on soit que plus de résilience et la
bonne chose on l'a vu quand ça arrive ça
devrait pas arriver ça suit aussi ce que
les américains ont fait récemment vous
avez peut-être vu le 6 juillet dernier
la commission fédérale des
communications
elle aussi demandé qui est des mesures
qui soient prises pour avoir plus de
résilience en cas d'urgence dont on
s'inspire de saumon voit plus loin et
moi je leur ai dit j'ai été clair j'ai
dit ça c'est le début vous n'avez pas
fini avec moi j'ai dit une fois que le
crtc enquête et or fait des
recommandations on voit revenir avec des
mesures additionnelles et regardez aussi
les meilleures pratiques pour mieux
comprendre ce qui s'est passé le
prévenir c'est un peu comme dans des
désastres aérien on va vers la cause on
essaie de comprendre pas ok bon
maintenant qu'on a compris il faut plus
jamais que ça arrive qu est ce qu on
peut faire passer lors qu'on on va
insister pour que ces mesures ne soient
prises et là vous vous adressiez ou
patrons des principaux fournisseurs mais
en particulier évidemment au patron de
rogers qu'est-ce que vous exigez de
rogers en particulier à partir de
maintenant d'abord qui entre dans cet
accord-là et le président était tout à
fait d'accord sur les trois items que
j'ai mentionné l'assistance rituel
l'itinérance en cas d'urgence les
protocoles mais aussi l'indemnisation
moi je vais parler aussi au nom des
canadiens canadiens nous écouter les
gens s'attendent à une indemnisation
proactive et adéquat adéquate ça veut
dire quoi parce que là on a évoqué deux
jours de crédit sur une facture
mensuelle est-ce que ça c'est adéquat où
ça en prend plus bas ce sera à eux de
voir au niveau commercial cette décision
là j'ai vu aussi que certains tribunaux
qui ont été saisis mais moi je leur ai
demandé de faire la chose à faire je
pense que ils ont besoin de rétablir la
confiance de leurs clients et le message
était on ne peut plus clair aujourd'hui
je vous dirais qu'il y avait beaucoup d
coûte aujourd'hui sur ce que j'avais à
dire et surtout cette volonté l'autre de
faire mieux plus de qualité plus de
redondance dans nos systèmes plus de
résilience et tous les pdg qui était là
aujourd'hui il y en avait sept tout le
monde était d'accord que on va faire
mieux évidemment soyons clairs c'est un
cetain c'est une erreur de la part de
rogers seller en jeu par contre ceci dit
maintenant faut s'assurer qu'on
comprenne des mesures additionnelles
pour avoir plus de résidence bon cette
erreur là cette panne attire le regard
sur le marché qu'on a dominé par
quelques grands géants attire
l'attention donc sur le projet de fusion
rogers et chats excuse à votre avis à
ajouter aux arguments que vous avez déjà
pour vous opposer à une transaction qui
réduirait par exemple la concurrence ben
ça sera dans l'esprit vous savez moi
depuis le début mars à eternoz j'ai été
clair je dit que je ne permettrai pas
communiste l'industrie le transfert de
l'ensemble des licences d'opérateur de
show de radio ça je le dis très clair
pourquoi parce qu'on veut plus de
compétitions pour vu des prix plus
abordables au pays on sait que la
meilleure façon d'y arriver c'est pas
une science tellement compliqué on sait
que la compétition ça amène des
meilleurs prix alors on veut continuer
dans cette veine là c'est clair que ce
qui est arrivé ça démontre aussi que
avoir plus d'opérateurs ça sert bien les
intérêts parce que s'il arrive quelque
chose comme ça faut s'assurer que dans
l'intérêt national y ait plus de
redondance alors c'est clair que
j'aurais ça l'esprit lorsque je devrais
prendre une décision là dans les
prochains mois sur cette transaction là
il y aura aussi le bureau de la
concurrence qui doit s'exprimer le crtc
mais c'est clair que je conte de vus
aujourd'hui vont être à l'esprit des
différents opérateurs des différents
intervenants quand vous parlez de
redondance et ça faisait partie de vos
annonces aujourd'hui l'assistance
mutuelle donc si on comprend bien
lorsqu'un réseau ne fonctionne pas un
fournisseur pourrait grâce à un
partenariat ponctuel avoir accès au
réseau d'un concurrent est ce que les
entreprises vous leur donnez le choix ou
vous leur imposez nom n'aurait pas donné
le choix par contre ça existait déjà de
façon informelle faut que je dois dire
je dois donner tout le crédit quand
c'est arrivé moi j'ai parlé au président
belge épargne au président de telus et
les deux de façon immédiate j'ai pas eu
la chance de parler à tout le monde vous
savez j'étais au japon quand tous est
arrivé mais quand j'ai parlé aux deux
pdg tout le monde voulait aider tout le
monde est conscient que dans l'intérêt
national si un enjeu comme celui là tout
le monde doit aider et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire je veux dire en termes très
concret l'assistance mutuelle ben ça
peut être au niveau des techniciens des
experts ça peut être au niveau aussi des
réseaux de la capacité parce que savoir
ce qui est arrivé non seulement ça
indiqué rogers mais s'impliquer aussi
les meilleurs experts à travers le monde
parce que pour arriver à comprendre ce
qui est arrivé aussi profond dans le
réseau de rogers c'est les experts
internationaux le qui sont intervenus
aussi pour mieux comprendre ce qu'on
appelle les vendeurs d'équipements les
équipementiers qui eux devaient
comprendre qu est ce qui est arrivé dans
leur système malgré tout ça a été long
et vous êtes là pour veiller au grain
pour les consommateurs ont le bien
compris merci beaucoup monsieur
champagne merci bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit